[Music]
come on
when I was younger I remember my twin
sister and I would go to a ranch and
there were these powerful horses and men
that would ride them these Shadows would
do these rope tricks up in the air and
it feels really Serene and picturesque
the horses themselves were really
Majestic
I remember riding all day and night with
a very cute brown horse named Kitty
growing up Mexican-American I have a
responsibility to create honest stories
that are reflection of my childhood I
learned a lot from my family there who
tended to these horses and showcased
that Vaquero and Shadow lifestyle to me
there is a certain amount of leadership
that revolves around that lifestyle and
I reflect that in my work now being a
leader and having to be responsible to
tell a story
foreign
telling have always been one I remember
when I was about six years old I'd wake
up to the son of my mother about 6 45 in
the morning knocking on my bedroom door
come to me really close and recite a
little prayer to me and in that prayer
she would always finish with
which means may God bless and protect
you
I didn't know it at the time but I've
learned the significance of that moment
and I think it was her way of saying I'm
not sure if I'll see you again but I'm
always with you
you see my mother was a person who grew
up with faith
and she would try to instill that faith
into us
my job as a cinematographer is to create
images that hold meaning and I'm able to
take those same lessons that she's
brought down to me
and try to make them feel extraordinary
and share it with the people around me
[Music]
I've always felt closest to my culture
when eating the food and a big reason
for that is because I'm Abuelita
foreign was always cooking up something
good in the kitchen and when Christmas
came around everyone was looking towards
one dish in particular her tamales
she would bring them in the sunflower
pot leave them in the kitchen and within
two hours they were gone
after she had passed we found ourselves
missing her more than ever Not only was
her presence gone and the recipes too it
felt like my title my culture had gone
away with her
it wasn't until we did some digging
where we found the recipe to recreate
our tamales although nothing's ever
going to beat the real deal we were able
to honor her through the food that she
left behind and re-tie the connection to
our culture
the new stories that I'm interested in
creating are stories that are focused
around authentic experiences and action
[Music]
stories are like recipes the better that
we preserve them the better that future
Generations can enjoy them
[Music]
to describe my family parties in one
word it would be
magical
foreign
we don't get together often but New
Year's everybody came to our house my
Theo my Theo would always be the first
to come we would start to have some
light music
[Music]
but as more people started to come more
crowded it got and the more alive the
party started to feel it creates a sense
of passion and love
when I edit I try to lead with that and
turn that into something special
[Music]
the stories I'm interested in creating
talk about the first generation
experience and now in a way that
victimizes or polarizes but in a way
that celebrates it's nice to see
yourself on screen
it's important to see that you exist
and that you matter
[Music]
please